So I know it's warm in here
and we just had a huge turkey lunch
but that doesn't mean we can loose focus
on how important our annual recap and planing meeting is
it is the only meeting we celebrate with a turkey lunch
Exactly. So let's all pay attention
Now forty seven...
I could do it.
Just get up and leave
I could be in costa rica by morning.
On the beach with a mamsita on each arm...
Dang, those mamasitas.
Get me every time.
But who am I kidding, I can't leave
These people need me
I love meetings.
The structure
The notes, the smell.
Everyone's here, no one's on Facebook.
And plenty of opportunities to raise my hand. Then...
It's Anna time.
I wonder what the woman I'm gonna marry is doing right now
She's probably at work
Or maybe she's showering
No Eliot! You haven't earned that yet!
She is a lady and you will respect her.
I'm sorry I yelled at you.
Is this mole new?
Could it be melanoma?
Am I too young to worry about my legacy?
Or am I too old?
What do I define the meaning of my life by?
... Except Kaylen
Oh shit, what was she saying?
Do I nod and say yes?
But what if she said something racist?
I can't fall for that again
Alright stay calm. But the whole crowd grows so loud...
He opens his mouth but the words won't come out
He's chocking. How?
Everybody's joking now.
The clock's run out, time's up, over now!
I really think we should focus on our legacy.
I mean, uh, nowadays everyone wanna talk like they got something to say, but nothing comes out when...
You did it Natalie. You had no idea what you were talking about, but no one noticed.
You fakeded it 'til you maded it.
No, 'faked it 'til you maked'
I don't think any of these are words.
Good meeting!
Who wants leftovers?